[Music]
my name is Ari I'm a product manager on
Google cloud within the cloud healthcare
organization and the title of this panel
is telemedicine a global perspective so
I'm very honored and fortunate to host
four of our partners representative from
four different organizations and they
would like to share with you some
aspects of the work of what our partners
are doing and kind of some of the
commonalities some of the interesting
idiosyncrasies of what they're seeing in
their respective fields and geographies
what love to the extent that makes sense
to share a little bit of how Google is
approaching the space and how is our
cloud platform and technology helps play
a role in this context so maybe we can
start by each one of our participants
introduce themselves and kind of the
mission and the organization that they
they represent good morning everyone my
name is Laurence or it's Otto I come
from Italy I serve as a technical
director for two companies one is a
telemedicine teller ideology company
active in Italy and the second one is we
provide cloud services for archiving and
distribution of medical images and the
name of the company is autry enterprise
hi my name is Turkish Katya from Amnesty
this company in 2000 in Hiroshima Japan
we have two strong points wise our
network network of doctors modern 70
doctors I enrolled and worked together
and another is system our system our
original system for image diagnosis we
developed that on the base of cloud GP
and leveraging leveraging those two
strong points we are trying to
experiment that the possibility the
availability of the the terror ology as
a title of this session
a very confident there Tutera audiology
can bring lots of merits to a society
outside it hasn't and no doubt yet
we want to bring out its full potential
okay
hi everyone I'm Dan Melora I'm the CEO
of rad aid international so we're a
nonprofit organization that brings
radiology to low resource regions
developing countries we were founded in
2008 to address the problem that
radiology is missing and about half to
two-thirds of the world that means that
all the medical images that are so vital
for diagnosing and treating disease are
mostly absent in in these low and
middle-income countries we have about
11,000 volunteers that go to these
countries to build radiology capacity so
that might mean donating equipment doing
trainings education for health personnel
to use medical imaging in a way that can
benefit the patients a large port a
large part of what we do now is also
donating the IT infrastructure and
bringing in packs and other IT
infrastructures that are vital for
bringing the images from the scanners
over to the workstations so that they
can be interpreted which of course
raises the big opportunity for long term
artificial intelligence development and
other advanced IT infrastructures so
it's great work that we love doing and
it's great to be here thanks hello
everyone I'm Raphael co-founder and CEO
of portal we are at alla diagnostic
platform that connects clinics hospitals
and governments our goal is to provide
access to quality healthcare and
especially in remote areas so we develop
a technology that integrates with
medical devices so the nurse usually or
a general physician do the exam data is
automatically transferred to the cloud
and the medical specialists like a
neurologist or cardiologist make the
diagnostic online these results is
available in the same day to our network
of clients of 500 hospitals and 300
cities in Brazil and Africa through our
proprietary data set of about
million patients we train machine
learning models running intensive flow
to automatic detect diseases in these
exams so wherever the ML model detect
the disease it a sinus risk score and
move it up into cuter emergencies so
this is how we do such a large scale
because we use ml to prioritize their
emergence so the doctors do that
Diagnostics on top of this our go here
and next we're looking for partners to
help in this global expansion and in our
mission to provide universal access to
healthcare
thank you thank you folks so this is a
this has been actually a personal dream
of mine to bring like people from
solving a very similar challenge in
different geographies and kind of trying
to find like what's common and what's
what idiosyncratic in my mind I was
calling it the medical imaging Olympics
we have representatives from four
different geographies so it sounds like
the problem we're all trying to approach
your organization's is like increasing
access to quality care right like so you
have expertise in one place and you have
the people who need could benefit from
in a different place what do you find
idiosyncratic like what's kind of unique
from your observation and your
conversations with colleagues from other
parts of the world and that might be
unique to your geography and we don't
have necessarily to go by order whoever
feels like they have something jump in
okay so what I see is similarities and
difference first is the matter of
legislation I believe each of us has a
different scenario to operate and
especially then when people say Africa
is on Africa a lot of different
countries with different regulation we
think the case of the u.s. is different
states so for example in Brazil I would
have one legislations federal and with
this legislation we can do the agnostic
Between the States with no problem here
in the US there are several states that
doesn't allow the license for the other
states so you need to hire local doctors
which it's one of the barriers of the
option of teletig gnostics here and also
in terms of technology I'm surprised to
see that what I thought was a problem in
Brazilian emerging markets for example
interoperability that the systems don't
talk between them and the devices also
they have a lot of problems that
proprietary files
we're seeing similar issues happen in
the US and Europe as well for different
reasons maybe like very big vendors that
don't want to integrate as opposed in
Brazil we have a lot of smaller vendors
which do want to integrate so I see it's
a matter of technical challenge most
emerging markets are here and some
places in Europe as more as a political
challenge between these big players but
it's nice to see that we have a lot of
similarities between the way that we
work and this is one of the reasons that
we are using GCP because there's some
infrastructure challenges there years
similar between us and Google is helping
us to solve this yeah so Raphael's right
there's a lot of heterogeneity diversity
across these locations red aid works in
30 countries and about 55 hospitals so
we see a lot of differences across these
locations I think the big thing that
we're finding that's a do sink radicand
important to point out is that with all
this technology development and the
algorithms and what's coming for the
future of artificial intelligence in
healthcare and medicine rad Aid is here
to empower the user there there is still
a gap between the user which is the
healthcare professional and the great
technologies that are capable so by
empowering the user we're talking about
really retraining healthcare workers to
think a little differently in their
clinical practice and how they adopt
technologies into their daily work and
that's something we can do by
integrating things like cloud and AI
into the practice of healthcare and
we're finding that that's going to
require a lot of on-site work and a lot
of understanding of what the uniqueness
characteristics are of these hospitals
and how they work in their cultures and
appreciating what that heterogeneity
might be but at the same time leveraging
the great technologies that are coming
from this kind of context talking about
a common feature of Terry audiology
especially this is a
similarly with the dance rather Aida
please let me explain about our Mongol
project now we're proceeding a three
years project with Mongol doctors every
year we have we hold one-week training
similar in our office in Hiroshima Japan
inviting a Mongolian doctors in that
seminar firstly we teach them how to did
not to interpret because Mongolian
doctors are still a little bit behind in
their diagnostic skills so we teach them
how to read how to interpret but rather
we focus on teaching them how to use our
system that's because that's a kind of
preparation for ear learning of course
one-week training seminar that's not
enough to build strong skills so after
the after that the seminar is over there
they're back to their hometown and while
making diagnosis in their daily job they
consult with us via our system Oh doc I
think this tumor is not malignant do you
agree or disagree the kind of thing one
doctor told me oh this is a ideal
platform for consultation we can discuss
seeing the same images at one time and I
we can do that with doctors all over the
world and not only us but you and you we
all can do that because that's cloud
that's cloud that clouds mmm
power value Terri audiology and cloud
are inseparable thank you okay I believe
that one of the main problems is a
standardization as a Reformation and we
have let's say we face really big
complexities with the collection of data
around the territory and
but as soon as they reach the cloud it's
all done and we have no complex scenario
to face and of course we also face
regulation problems as you as you know
in Europe we have from since 2000 may
2018 new general data protection
regulation which is really strict and we
have a we have to collect concerns from
the from the patients and all the
process must be audited and must be
transparent so this is this made of
course easy we do Google Cloud
since the platform itself itself is GDP
our GDP our compliant and thank you
folks so one thing I want to point out
that kind of stood out to me is like one
of the easier sink recedes I remember
when first learning about MMS work is
that as a data point and in the US and
in Japan you have a comparable number of
medical imaging devices like CTS and
MRIs very similar maybe 10 different 10%
15% difference but the number of doctors
radiologists in Japan is I think 7 times
less so it creates a huge scarcity for
radiology
so it's an interesting kind of dynamic
that makes you realize that ok this
resource is very valuable I need to
optimize it effectively and one thing I
want to ask you like I'm if I ask how
many people have spoken to a daughter on
the phone here right majority people
have so in some sense they're kind of a
basic telemedicine right you're talking
to a doctor remotely so the phones have
been since Alexander bell and interent
has been around in the 80s so what does
cloud change
or or is it just faster Internet how are
you thinking about that piece well I
believe that with cloud we the time is
the speed of the process is much higher
of course
so the I I am in the sector since 20
years so I I saw the phases we for
example for our teleradiology projects
we we used to have our own data center
and we used to move point-to-point all
the DICOM images so the biggest projects
we had they were mammography screening
tell radiology projects so it was really
a big big pain to to move the images
from the server to the single point to a
single workstation of the radiologist
that were that was reporting from home
for example so it was really a long
process and many people were involved to
monitor all the workflow and but now
with with a cloud we it takes some
minutes so we collect the images we
collect the priors so that the actual
study plus the priors and then they are
immediately available to everyone on
whatever device
they want to use of course they are
using multi-monitor were stations so it
takes minutes from acquisition to
reporting so this is a in my opinion is
one of the best the most important point
and of course there are less mistakes in
the in the process because it's is
simplified by technology as totally as
re told in Japan the ratio of radio just
to scanners that ratio is ridiculously
low in Japan comparing with other
countries we have many many scanners CT
or MRI scanners but the number Brady
ologist is strictly limited and last
year in Japan overlooked cancers became
a social problem very famous large
respected hospitals announced one by one
after another that they did overlooked
and suddenly some resulted in patient's
death that gained nationwide attention
and as a result as you can tell the
result is raised expectation for terror
ideology the radiologists are shortened
numbers so in order to centralize and
make it more efficient radio terror
ideology is essential indispensable and
and in the point cloud and terror
audiology is insupportable and cloud is
essential thank you
cloud brings down costs and lowers
complexity it's the basic two
deliverables that a cloud can bring into
a low resource environment so for
example this past year ratted with
Google cloud as well as Umbra and a
logistics company tribal Co implemented
a solution where you know there was Lau
friends hospital for children this was a
low resource hospital and Laos
had no radiology department at all
practically three or four years ago and
we started there now
for them to have PACs right this is the
architecture for sending the images from
the scanners to the workstations for
them to have done that using a
conventional solution Rati has done that
we've sent these large racks these large
servers to places that had to build a
climate-controlled server room and do
their own storage but that was very
complex and very costly imagine a low
resource hospital having to build all
that infrastructure and then have all
that IT personnel within the hospital to
manage it it's a very difficult scenario
to manage so instead so the pilot we did
with Google Cloud in Laos for example we
came down with a compact server now that
we could hand carry that's temperature
resistant so it didn't need any climate
control at all and had all the preloaded
Armour packs software onboard already
went to the hospital and turned it on
connected it to the imaging modalities
so that it would have on-site storage
but as well would immediately back up to
the cloud which was the Google Cloud
which were calling ratted friendship
cloud in this instance so it it overcame
all of these logistical barriers that
could have occurred otherwise and then
also dramatically lowered the cost so
what cloud introduces is it lowers the
barrier to entry for low resource
hospitals to implement their IT
infrastructure by having a way to really
turnkey transfer images from scanners to
workstations and then have a way to back
up those images I'm gonna share one of
that clinical example that we have for
machine learning we use tensorflow for
the last two years since the first
versions and back then back there we had
I think about ten models because these
models are very narrow so it's a one
model for a chest x-ray we're not gonna
work in Nike G's and other working TCS
are very specific and every time I try
to train one of those models in our own
VMs for example we took about five weeks
for each of these models get trained in
these meters of examples so just imagine
the arm and this
psycho for the developers who have to
wait five weeks see if the model is
better or not than the last version so
we've been to a program that Google has
called Launchpad estudio is an
acceleration program for tech companies
last year and our goal was to apply the
continuous integration parity in machine
learning so the thought of continuous
delivering new models and the way that
you do we did that we port all the
models that we have for cloud ml engine
with it's a manager managed tensorflow
that you can just choose the metric and
the data set and it train it for you so
which you should take five weeks right
now is to get is taking two days so how
it works now we get a data set for
example for chest x-ray is one of the
simplest one we have a list of findings
nodules to be pneumonia consolidation
and each of those models instead of just
one being trained in a VM for five weeks
we can put a 100 different containers to
be trained at the same time and each of
those containers have different neural
network architectures different layer
sizes and different processing
techniques on this and because it's a
pretty much a trial and error still deep
learning you don't know exactly what
will impact if you change layers for
example so what we do put this 100
container should be trained at the same
time with just one script that call this
API each of these containers will have a
different configuration of the neuro net
for example and then after one to two
days they 100 are trained and we collect
the metrics but instead of collecting
the regular metrics of memory later in
CPU for example we collect those as well
but we also collect the metrics from the
confusion matrix intensive flow so
accuracy and recall these are collects
automatically and the model that have
the best performance go to production
the other 99 are killed and this is
started again so which 48 hours will
retrain our whole models again with the
new data that is coming from these 500
hospitals and right now this is
happening without us having to like
press any buttons it's happening like
actually we're doing this weekly so
every Saturday night we train with a new
data from the week and but with these
variations of architectures
and layers and stuff like this so right
now and since regard is about eight
months ago right now I have 200
different models they are running in
production classifying these diseases so
this is one example of how it became
scalable and now our engineers or mio
genus can focus on the models itself and
not in the plumbing around and when you
stop to see like machine learning work I
would say that about 90 percent of the
work is the plumbing it's like the
health education is data engineer
organizing ingesting these data and ten
percent is actually PhD machine learning
work and if you give the speech these to
do the other part to the DevOps part
they would take like three four times
what a good cloud developer would would
take so it's a way to to speed up the ml
work which is actually usually high
paying per hour people that don't know
how to do the cloud infrastructure but
they are very good at math and
mathematics so do keep them focus on
what you're good at and the cloud take
care of all the plumbing around so I
guess when you bring up AI and medicine
or radiology the natural questions is
like you know will what will what is the
role that AI will play in kind of
changing the dynamics being a doctor and
a patient and there is the elephant in
the room kind of question will a I
replace doctors may be one central
specialties how do you use AI in your
organization and what's your take on
this kind of changing role of a doctor
and will AI replace or augment doctors
well in our opinion in my opinion
I is augments doctors and so far in our
organization we implemented some some
models for prioritizing as you mentioned
before and also to let's say to segment
segment studies in order to assign the
studies to the right doctor so I don't
know for example mammography dense
breasts so we are more difficult to - of
course - to report so what the model
does is a classification of brands
breast density and then if the if of
course if the study is a dense breast
it goes to an expert radiologist and so
this is a lowers the risk for the
patient in my opinion in the future to
be more and more so why not maybe
radiologist four will be replaced maybe
for routine works routine reporting and
we'll have more time to concentrate on
let's say most difficult cases I believe
so talking about AI I want to share the
identical situation in Japan our own
constitution of approval in Japan
through the the collaboration with
start-up area vendors we have developed
several a eyes and our doctors or and
lower the doctors have used them since
more than two years ago and now so now
they they know a lot about AI good and
bad its usefulness and its limits both
but maybe we Japanese are very
conservative people and they our
National Health Ministry has a
just one AI by now many benders have
developed and many a eyes but still just
one approval and on the media or among
doctors the probe that called pros and
cons of AI still remains as a matter of
dispute but then from the viewpoint of
our doctors the doctors with lots of
experience of AI from the from their
point of view that dispute seems to be
irrational one-dimensional for example
some doctors expect too much
OAS going to do many many things with
100% accuracy or no no no or some others
fear too much OAS going to drive us out
of business
no my take is just give them the
opportunity of hands-on air trial as
well as possible after a couple of weeks
of using AI maybe they know and they
will realize that reality a good and bad
and that dispute would be more realistic
more down-to-earth and I think that
would be a beneficial for our health
ministry - this is a great question I'm
a radiologist so I'm right in the middle
of this I say I gonna replace me for
example most of us believe at this point
that AI is going to increase quality and
increase efficiency but it can't really
replace the human caregiver human
patients really need a human caregiver
it's the human condition so no one's
trying to advocate that machine should
take over this particular role but it
can improve the speed at which we do
things and the quality at which we do
things so a couple of you know examples
have been suggested like a basic triage
role for triaging the different cases
ones that are abnormal from normal or
ones that deserve immediate attention
versus ones that can wait acute disease
or emergency versus something that's
chronic and can be dealt with in a
different velocity in the in the
tear context so these are different
scenarios that AI can can deliver but
what's very true and we just mentioned
is that AI is really not in our context
yet when I go to work on a daily basis
there is no AI that I'm aware of in my
midst but it is in the future so we're
trying to incorporate it into the vision
of what the profession will have but
what's also important though is that
once you start integrating AI into the
clinical care workflow you're really
changing the way that doctor is going to
do their job and that means retraining
that person for how their job is now
influenced by this new capability so it
doesn't transfer very easily it doesn't
just happen overnight because that
doctor is still responsible for the life
of the patient
so they're not just going to hand it
over so like you just heard only one
approval of an AI mechanism so far I
mean that's not surprising because we're
talking about that the fact that the
human care on the other side is still at
risk if that AI doesn't work so that
transfer needs to happen in a way that's
careful and trained so I think what
comes from this is a great interest in
education for health providers to really
think about how they would use AI in
those workflows I'm gonna open with a
fun quote that what is AI because if I
heard like if he's reading in vitamin c
plus plus it's probably machine learning
if he's reading in powerpoint is
probably AI and so we need to
differentiate things and in our case was
a matter of adoption for the doctors
because we started to trust these models
but how you approach the doctors you use
it and in our case in health care
specifically cannot be an end in itself
you need to be a mean to something and
once we started to do a lot of daily
Diagnostics we started to hit the first
bottleneck which was prioritization so
even if we give the results in same day
24 hours can be too much depend of the
case so we approach the doctors in a
very lightweight
what you
think if you prioritize the Emergencies
and then we run about six months of a
dual pipeline of the predictions against
a regular nurse prioritizing things for
them I would have a nurse full-time that
take care of this and it was obvious
that the prioritization made by but ml
models was being better and faster
milliseconds and so they they agreed and
then after one year using this when do
we hit about 90% recall which is very
low false negatives we trained
everything for recall first specificity
we say okay now with just enough in
these models to do a double check so if
the algorithm predicts for example
pneumothorax that could be fatal if not
treated you move it up in the queue in
seconds you get to the radiology but if
he clicks normal you didn't see it
because you can have very small team on
torques then the system sent to three
other doctors and create a Board of
consensus between them of course it's a
blind test for all of them they think
the first opinion but then with this we
could rule out this kind of mistakes and
then a data point it's not me saying as
I stirred by Harvard which is the doctor
precision is around 80% depend of the
modality of course but when you stop if
you think about it of 100 stage one
concert with a very small nodule 80 will
be found in to any not probably gonna be
diagnostic lead with a stage 203 so now
when you approach the doctor okay if you
made a mistake
the system was sent to three other
doctors so this kind of small things
you're not gonna be a liability for you
and then they'll say ok let's try it
same thing we did a dual pipeline and
they started to trust the models and now
you're using this of those 200 models
that we have with all of them
prioritization and you have 40 that we
trust enough to do the double check and
so it's a matter of how you're
approaching and unless like example is
that how what is the KPI is that the
doctors are looking for is different
KPIs for us as the köppen imagine this
platform but for then most of the times
is how many diagnostics I can do per
hour in a safe way and because the unit
economists need to make sense to have
good doctors on board doing these
Diagnostics they need to get a same
dollar per hour as they give
and they were having a hospital in a
shift in the hostel for example so their
way to speed up these things with with
this prioritization and double-check and
with decision trees that they click
instead of type like for example a
neurologist will click epilepsy diffuse
frontal lobe diagnose so with this we
speed up about ten ten times how many
Diagnostics they do per hour but they
know if they click the miss click
something new happened they do thousands
per day this will go to other doctors so
it was all a matter of how you approach
then and how you show the benefit and
not the technology itself they actually
don't care if it's running intensive
flow in the cloud and on-premise but
they need to know there is helping them
to make it safe so we believe that when
you combine the doctor and their mothers
you can hit the 99% accuracy lots of
lots of good ideas one one thing I would
like to share from from our perspective
AI is not going to replace radiology but
I think radiologists that use a I could
replace radiologists that don't use AI
because the AI is yet another tool it's
like saying I'm not gonna use a computer
I'm not gonna use digital technology I
know there is the Internet it's just
gonna make the quality and the the
productivity is lower level so i we
think AI might be another tool in the
arsenal of doctors that are helping
patients in this context I wanna like
this I think the topic came up like
numbers and economics and like who pays
for this so I'm actually curious so then
you represent a non profit sector and
the you folks represent the commercial
organization so like in your geographies
in your markets like what kind of
economic trends or maybe forces you are
seeing like for example in the US where
there is a payer in the provider and
oftentimes they kind of have this
interesting balance between them who's
gonna pay for this
AI new AI service portfolio how does it
plane in your markets this is a very
interesting question well to tell you
the truth for example in Italy
we we
the payer is usually the government so
we have a public health system and they
have really a lot of difficulties in
incorporating these new technologies
into their payments so so far for
example not even teleradiology
is inside these lists of services that
the government pays so of course the
since artificial intelligence algorithm
lower the risks and at the end of course
they you make you save money in my
opinion for example the the radiologists
themselves and the organizations and for
example the insurances that cover the
organizations and the radiologists
should should pay for them for these
tools because the risk lowers I can't
tell the financial aspect of AI but as I
mentioned in Japan the number of
scanners are very very many we have many
scanners but the number of radiologists
is limited so to cover that shortfall we
need not only teri radiology but we need
also AI I can tell to what extent but
more or less will be introduced in
medicine and AI will work together with
radiologists and then cover the
shortfall in that context Japan ranks
top as the car the country that needs AI
and terror ideology bowls
to answer the question about who would
pay for a I first I would put it out
there for all of you to think about how
exactly will a I be delivered to these
clients these medical clients because
right now if you think about AI coming
about with in packs well then that means
that a packs vendor will license or
build itself AI and put it into the
product remember packs is a closed
system no one can just open up packs and
add new software into it it's closed so
it goes to the client and then they just
use it as is so essentially that
hospital would be paying the PAC's
vendor for whatever is in it so they
would be passing that cost through to
the hospital through the price of the
packs same goes for hardware if you
think about CT ultrasound MRI or
mammography machinery that can also
embed AI within the equipment so again
it'll be included as product
advancements that then get sold to the
hospitals in that kind of dynamic then
when we think about well who pays for it
short term middle term long term that's
where the difference between nonprofit
and private sector and public sector
actually becomes very relevant
especially in low and middle income
countries as a non-profit we have a much
higher risk tolerance than any of the
others do in private sector and
government because we're mission driven
and we can afford to lose money right we
can go and do something for the sake of
mission to put something in place
because we know the patients need it so
in the short term a non-profit like rad
aid can have a very high tolerance for
that risk whereas private sector will be
very reluctant to take risk like that
initially but then once non profit can
show that something is workable a pilot
or something is sustainable that that's
where that risk kind of reduces and that
return on investment becomes more
palatable to private sector and that's
why it's very important to consider the
private and nonprofit sector
partnerships then as you get into the
middle term that medium term of you know
nonprofits and private sectors
partnering in that regard that's when
government really does come into
play as a long-term solution because
then you're bringing in the fact that no
governments are never going to get
involved in that initial stuff that
actually has high risk that nonprofits
can do but for long term for public
sector and you know providing public
goods to the population that makes more
sense for government so short term for
high-risk innovation nonprofits are well
positioned in this space and then for
short to middle term you've got private
sector partnerships and then for the
long term you have a government actor
also coming together and that's how a
lot of innovations have come into
healthcare and I would say that it's
probably going to be along similar lines
in this case to agree with what then
said about how a I will be delivered I
think this is the main point to think
who will pay for it and this is in our
case of healthcare like deep link to
regulation again so for example here in
the US you can do telecom sorting so
there's doctrine on demand tell a doctor
you talk through your doctor through a
video in Brazil cannot do this in each
be B to B not B to C never a patient can
call us directly in each go to a local
small clinic and this clinic will then
access all these specialists in their
hospitals if you follow these rules you
are doing a B to B it can be a video
call but our main go it's exams
Diagnostics on top of x-rays MRIs etc
then it's fully reimbursed so it doesn't
matter if it's a local doctor or as a
remote doctor in San Paulo the
government or the insurance will
reimburse atelic including your tele
Diagnostics so they'll way that we did
we embedded our AI costs or machine
learning costs per tests per report
so whatever report change hands we
receive an amount for this and the
doctor get paid and the inherent cost of
GPU these are like GPU RS or API calls
but there is a call there is a price per
test so when you embed this per report
and then the report is fully reimbursed
then the AI causes diluted on this and
and in that way the government and the
insurers are paying for if I approach
the insurance and say pay the API call
here this is not gonna understand it but
if this is embedded in the workflow so
this is why I say cannot be an end in
itself it needs to be admin to deliver
something
then is fully reimbursed I do have
another case where AI was this like
important for us we want to beat with
the San Paulo public health care last
year and so they required a platform and
there is a price for AI but it's not
specifically on the bid say we're gonna
pay X amount for the AI they were asking
for like features for example we need
probabilistic matching of patients
between different systems because
different last names
so this is one of the feature that they
have we need to be able to prioritize
emergencies with machine learning was
one of the things we need to be able to
out it our previous exam so they have 20
meter exams for the last 10 years and
now we are running our models
historically on this and finding like
cancers that was Diagnostics as normal
and then we can like create clusters and
alerts and call these patients again so
it wasn't like have a price tag price on
this but being able to have this
features was the difference to warn the
beat and then the price is the full
platform so it depends off how you
deliver and legislation of course so I'm
I'm hearing that it's a complex issue
we'll probably won't resolve in next
eight minutes tonight and one thing I
want to ask each one of you is like what
are you most excited are you and your
teams are most excited about for this
year like what are you anticipating what
could help you accelerate we're excited
about it we have many projects together
every so you already know the answer but
like this beat that I mentioned with the
some Paulo public healthcare it's one of
the things so what we did in the private
sector with this 500 hospitals it took
six years one by one bottom up and now
we have this network that is connected
is running well now we want to take this
to large scale so we started to work
with the Sao Paulo government it's a
pilot of 35 million seats since 20 years
and when it works we then take this to
the federal level so we're now kind of
developing a playbook of how to speed
these implementations so what takes
years now for example we take about 18
months to implement
a new network in the city if it's a
clinic we can install now in one day he
used to take one week two weeks and now
it we stall one clinic per day but now
to take this broadly and faster we want
to learn how to do a full country in 90
days so this is our objective with
Google right now we are expanding fast
to public healthcare and different from
the private we like people are paying
for its as governmental projects you
need to be very low-cost to be able to
be sustainable after we deliver the
platform so all this cost engineering is
getting way more important right now
because we need to deliver a to that
then is sustainable without us taking
care and then disconnecting all the
healthcare centres so I think right now
we are shifting our minds of Lublin by
one hostels to a more broader view of
population or health care management
where we applying the same algorithms
that we did one by one on top of weight
larger and more at erogenous datasets
and one thing that it's nice is that
when you compare the metrics that we
have with the top papers from MIT
Stanford we've seen that the algorithm
that they train I train on top of the
instant the Stanford hospital with the
last GE device and when you try to apply
this in emerging markets datasets with
different devices different DNA's you're
not going to generalize you're going to
lose a lot of precision and accuracy on
this and we are true to see that since
we train this in different devices in
300 cities from from the top G Sao Paulo
for lower tier devices some are for
example a Chinese device or a Brazilian
device and now when you apply these new
data from new hospitals you're
generalizing very well so one of the
things is that you need to take the bias
out of the data sets to be able to then
apply this to different populations and
we see that our experience in the six
years was worth it
so we're like go right now is to speed
up this to implement in more countries
I'm very excited about the partnership
we have for developing an ecosystem for
AI developers to interface with the
hospitals where ratted serves as I said
by building clouding architecture and
building capacity in those hospitals
that creates an ability for AI
developers to work with ratted and to
work with those hospitals to bring AI
into existence for those hospitals and
this would be an open-source system this
would be a way for developers to learn
more about what these hospitals need
this would increase data diversity by
bringing these hospitals into those
repositories that really need to be more
diverse for that AI to be accurate so
this is an important endeavor we're
taking over the next year we invite the
AI development community to work with us
on this to really make this a dream come
true as an ecosystem for AI development
and healthcare to be together
now we're pursuing a project with the
Google brain team in that project we are
building we are developing an
infrastructure to exchange images and a
result hospitals and clinics like us
have send images to Google and on Google
side air scans and analyzes those images
and then display the result and very
soon we can complete it and show it to
you
and as I mentioned to vendors parks
vendors I think we should change the
present situation the situation of
bender dependent medicine I think we
should use AI like other other internet
system internet services say a Google
search when you type a keyword and click
a button and you get the result which we
can and we should a use AI that way and
I yeah that infrastructure is not only
for this project but in the near future
it will be one essential part of AI
diagnosis system our works that
infrastructure can support doctors all
over the world that's a great honor for
us we are excited as a company for and
we have some new projects on ai with
with regional governments so we are
collecting data from them and then we
are developing with them artificial
intelligence tools and so of course
exciting for for the company just want
to add on what Takashi and Ann said on
the ecosystem would definitely take a
ecosystem approach so our view from
Google Cloud we want to enable
application developers to bid AI
applications in health care and in
radiology generally because these
applications tend to be very narrow and
it's gonna take hundreds maybe thousands
of applications we believe that it will
take an entire ecosystem to Bella
develop this effectively we spend we
invest where we can accelerate this
process for example how to develop by
their labeling tools or how to develop
better training tools but the
application themselves would be
developed but the ecosystem and we have
a minute left so I want to ask you in 10
seconds what's kind of your prediction
for the next 18 months lightning round
actually my prediction is the challenge
that we need to solve so I hope we
fulfill this prophecy but right now
these models they're very narrow so they
are same pneumonia I don't know the
monomyth Oryx I don't know
we're trying to break now is correlating
this with a lab test for example with
the HR and have a deep learning model
they actually look at multiple signs to
then do a proper teletig Gnostic because
we don't believe that only look at the
images enough even for a doctor so
imagine they either don't have any
knowledge of the world making
predictions on top of pixels only so
we're trying to cross these barriers and
create multi modality models that absorb
all kinds of healthcare signals I think
there'll be a full embrace of AI
education
in the clinical world that in the next
18 months you're gonna see a lot of
other medical professionals fully
embracing AI education in order to
prepare themselves for the next era
where AI will come into practice in the
in this in this event
Google next in every session in every
session related to healthcare every
speakers every panelists say the same
thing talking about the problem of
interoperability the kind of thing
to break them barriers I think and and
and that and now I'm very optimistic in
the long run and I think this change is
this can be a transition from
paternalism paternalistic medicine to
patient-centered medicine and that will
be a beneficial for patients thank you I
see that
standardization also in artificial
intelligence will become more and more
important so I'm sure Google Google
cloud will lead we lead the way in data
lab link for example or implementation
of ie annotation in the viewers this is
really important and it everyone is
doing some some private some private
annotation or some private data
labelling but this disease cannot
continue
[Music]